[Applause]
first up he is the former press
secretary to president trump and author
of radical nation joe biden and kamala
harris's dangerous plan for america sean
spicer give him a hand uh
sean
how are you okay i don't know are you a
handshaker okay
it's so it's so weird that we're shaking
hands they're all unmasked you know it's
just we'll get to that later but okay
okay but i'm glad we're back to doing
that and look uh i've seen you on tv
quite a bit first with trump appreciate
that and then uh i'm dancing with the
stars oh that too
thank you
oh see look at that
ironically it's the same lot you know
what's that it's a as you know it's the
same lot it's good to be back
yeah now i know you you have your book
there over your nuts i'm not gonna
uh don't worry sean this is not a
hostile intro okay
i can always get it back
no i i i i've been here for a long time
now i'm well aware of that i know
we're trying to say we're politically
incorrect we have to come together as a
country with the people on your side and
people on my side so i'm not here to
kick you in the nuts
good to know okay
but we do have disagreements i just
first of all i mean
dangerous plan for america the name for
the book tell me what now i look i've
also said on the show the 3.5 trillion
seemed like a lot of money for a country
that not that long ago never passed the
one trillion mark and i'm not sure
what's in it i don't think we spend
money wisely so i had reservations but
dangerous plan for america it seems like
all the conservative books are like
you're always playing this dangerous
radical card is it really look first of
all
i think it is i think you look at how
we're dealing with china how we withdrew
from afghanistan and the aftermath of
that what we're doing in the economy
inflation going rampant all of these
things are a concern of mine plus if you
can spend 3.5 trillion dollars and not
know what's in it and all you're doing
is shoveling out money so they do know
what's in it no they don't name them
there's not a single member of congress
that's read that
well they don't yeah no because it's a
thousand pages but we do know 1900 okay
every sean
i know we've not ever spent three point
five or six is a clip i just said that
but nobody ever knows what's in a giant
bill like that so let's just talk real
talk and not go to talking but it's what
it's being spent on okay but like i
remember you guys saying the exact same
thing about obamacare was going to be
the end of freedom it's been over a
decade it wasn't was it was it the i
think obamacare just to be clear i think
we're still dealing with the the
aftermath but number one obamacare
aftermath oh obamacare was just
housekeeping
what i'm talking about isn't related to
just one stimulus bill it's how we're
dealing with everything in this country
right now they want to do things like
negotiate drug prices
i'm fine with it but but that's but they
want to make dc a state they want to
pack the court all of these things i
think will radically and here's the
thing it's not my words the president on
friday said that i want to transform
this country three fridays ago he said
if we pass my legislation it will
fundamentally transform the structure
and nature of the country those are his
words not mine your is always saying
well they're out of water saying it i
know but like you're out of office two
days and the country is an irretrievable
[ __ ]
really i mean trump it's i i mean it's
amazing to me how fast it works because
the trump slogan is make america great
again again i couldn't have written that
tell me what what is 10 months in office
what is one thing
that
is going well that this administration
has done one thing well we did get out
of afghanistan now he did not stick the
landing on how it was done i will agree
with that but unlike the his
predecessors who talked about it and
didn't do it it was a big thing that had
to be done
oh i think we are going to regret how
we've done that for decades if not
generations the fact that we've lost all
food i know this kind of stuff doesn't
mean a lot to you but they also didn't
lift a lot of children out of poverty
with
i i the pandemic really
i mean that that does matter they i mean
like another thing they want to do
dental for seniors you know a lot of ill
health comes through the mouth yes no
joke sean i'm just saying
[Laughter]
maybe we did it earlier
it's a portal to it's like the kind of
thing that's pennies on the dollar if
you take care of seniors and they're
dental right but but i think the one
thing that and you started this at the
beginning there's a lot of things that
there's a shared goal but it's how we do
them yes right and too many times the
answer is a government institution that
is not well run is not efficient and we
end up for decades and generations
looking back and saying oh too bad so
we're just talking about the numbers
we're just talking about no we're
talking about how how to do it okay but
i think that you look at all of the
systems of government in terms of
especially health care the va medicare
medicaid none of them run well and now
we want to say hey let's have to get
back to this type of negotiating where
we're talking about i think this is a
reasonable discussion somewhat
as opposed to
q anon believes democrats eat babies you
know how do you negotiate with that
person it's like we'll bend a little on
the corporate tax rate if you stopped
eating babies but i don't think you are
good but you're not but that's it but
that's a big part of your constituency
no it's not oh are you
human is not so you renounce q anon of
course i do oh great i don't i don't eat
maybe not anymore no that's the others
they're accusing the other side oh
they're not q another eating sorry
they're saying the democrats eat babies
okay well
okay so you get that that's lunacy what
about what about the election was rigged
and trump really won is that i think
there are some serious problems with the
election here we go no no time out hold
on name uh when you look at pennsylvania
wisconsin nevada the idea that we
changed rules running up to an election
in terms of how about it when it was
counted do you think pennsylvania the
law signed by a democratic governor
19 acts 77 signed by governor wolf said
that all ballots had to be interviewed
there was a pandemic that's why they
changed the law they okay there was no
time to do that
so you should just never well you would
have no there wasn't there wasn't plenty
of time to pass legislation and all of
these others this is a rabbit hole you
want to go down avoid the question did
trump win or lose the election i don't
know well there you go
you